so the first thing to see is this is a
little bit like what did you polynomial
division when you do polynomial division
there remain two you get out of
something if I divide by X 1/2 or if I
divide a very expert with X plus 2 the
remainder is always one degree less than
the divisor if the degree of the
remainder is always wanted one less than
the degree of the divisor so that's what
I have here you see I've got a linear
remainder for a quadratic divisor and
here I've got another this is a constant
remainder for a linear divisor you see
that that's what I kind of this will
work let's just find a packet and see
what happens right so I'm gonna go over
here so I have other row space I'm gonna
expand it just like normal so I'm gonna
go
okay now at this point I could go ahead
and I could saw I'm gonna compare the
numerators but I'm gonna take them it
was right on suggestion before I think
to say well um it was someone's
suggestion to say well if I have it in
this form already right then I can
substitute in values for X that will
make certain terms disappear so long as
I remember this guy over here I'm really
just concerned with the numerators right
okay so I'm going to get rid of the
denominators for a second so I can
probably do this because we don't want
to substitute something in which makes
it denominator zero I'm gonna say four x
squared plus eight must be equivalent to
this
so now I'm gonna let X equal now what a
chooser value that will get rid of as
many things as I can and leave behind
one of the perennials okay so what am I
going to choose if I choose to that will
make this whole term becomes zero this
one becomes euro so it will leave behind
C so I can solve for C does that make
sense so I'm going to let X equal two I
have stuff on the left and on the right
yeah so this is now an equation by the
way once I put this in once I put this
in there will be only one value for C
Tzfat always true so I'm gonna say 4
times 4 plus 8 what's that equal to
I'm not going to up skip this guy cuz
I'm not gonna just say oh he just
disappears he actually becomes something
but then when I get to the next bit I'm
gonna say it is a C and this will become
4 plus 2 plus 2 and you can see already
what's happening right I've got I don't
know I have extra back there I got 1624
on the left and I've got XE on the right
I have value hurrah that's pretty good
ok one down two to go where would you
like me to go next what I do
mm-hmm okay so again if I'm trying to go
down this little top if I say let X
equal some other convenient value then I
can get towards like these guys over
here I could try it all happen if I let
it sanity
now if I let X equal zero
this guy will disappear that's good I
already know what this is so that will
leave behind this guy there are other
ways to do it I could do the whole
silent a so crazy bin but I'm happy with
that better way so let's give it a go on
the left hand side I'm gonna get a 0
plus 8 is equal to okay watch out here
do your substitution carefully I'm not
gonna skip anything because I dress
myself see here plus B 0 and minus 2 C 0
2 0 2 you happy with that this
opposition we go again I know what C is
right it's 3 so I'm going to simplify
and I'm going to substitute that in at
the same time I've got 8 there I've got
- to be TIA C is 3 times 2 years 6 ok
let's tidy this up subtract that gives
you minus 2 B being included - so B
looks to me like minus 1 okay
I've got C be just happen to be in
reverse order what would you like you to
do to do in what feels like the quickest
part is you get a
okay so I've done like this way putting
inconvenient values but I'm kind of done
for Canadian values right now I couldn't
like stop random with peeping other
things something work since I know a B
and C are but to me it looks like the
most direct path would be look all the x
squared terms have to come from here and
here
do you agree with that there's nowhere
else I could get x squared terms from so
I'm going to compare x squared terms
right one radix to x squared welcome to
the session saying what's the
coefficient of x squared on the left on
the left it's bull on the right hand
side you've got a x times X so that will
give you an x squared term and then
you've got c times x squared that'll
give you ever see no Suzy three so a is
equal to one you happy with that
so therefore four x squared plus eight
although boy did I put my eggs of bees
the season right spots yeah that's good
so conclusions like this method here
this method here
two simple institutions it leads you to
this problem here of you've over
simplified the question what this says
or rather when I get to here and I have
no solutions what this says is there's
no way and being that if you put cost in
terms up there you'll never get
something out the other end that is you
can try a sand-based forever if you like
and you will never end up do something
identical
you also can't just put it willy-nilly
okay some places you put it ends up
being no use to you at all so therefore
we're gonna put it here think about the
way to remember it is this guy is always
some kind of remainder from this guy
from dividing through by that that's why
this would be linear that's why this is
constant and God forbid if you had a
cubic factor you'd have a quadratic
remainder on numerator at the top okay